my favorite thing that happened this
past week and maybe in history was when
Mario Batali said sorry for sexual
harassment by the way try my Cinnabons
favorite thing that happened in the past
however many years
oh dude so sorry for being a [ __ ]
gross male Pig by the way these new
cinnamon desserts are great for the
holidays
hey man by the way he doubled down maybe
him he might be maybe that's the key to
keeping your career I mean they must
have fired him right but when he put the
[ __ ] email out where he was like I'm
so sorry I shouldn't have done this my
apologies by the way if you're looking
for a holiday treat that guy is a
sociopath he doesn't give a [ __ ] but
that guy just looks like a guy you know
what Mario Batali looks like he looks
like a guy who got a belly to be extra
creepy so he could lay his [ __ ]
interlaced fingers on it and be like my
my what great milky breasts to a woman
and then walk away and be like he
literally looks like Oh Mario Batali
looks like a guy who Dirk's off and then
by himself and then has an orgasm and
then laughed so hard afterwards because
I get was such a great release and he
left so hard that he can't that he
starts crying and then he's wiping tears
away like and then he cleans himself up
how much does Mario Batali only
masturbate with the windows open and
like the breeze coming in and he feels
the breezin it turns a mom cuz it's like
he's so relaxed he's like I just like
feeling the earth you know and then he
laughed so hard after he masturbates and
then he [ __ ] tears come out of his
eyes and then he's like ah [ __ ] and then
he goes to his own kitchen and makes
like some pork [ __ ] with like a nap with
that with like an apple [ __ ] sauce on
it [ __ ] my my those are beautiful milky
breasts that's
you know II I mean it looks like a guy
who would [ __ ] do that he looks like
I mean you don't grow your hair out you
don't grow your red hair out and get a
fat [ __ ] belly and wear a [ __ ]
Patagonia fleece vest while you're
cooking to not look at women and say my
what a figure
I mean come on the guy looks like a
[ __ ] pimp give him a you know what he
I mean give him a cane give him a
[ __ ] bunch of rings and put a [ __ ]
fur coat on him with oversized gold
glasses and make him smack hoes and get
money
my my how evil not not surprised for a
second not surprised for a second also
take off your Crocs duty was orange
Crocs who I mean this guy looks like a
guy who would be like blah blah blah and
grab girls butts
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba that turns him on uh what
I by the way I thought he was gay I I
thought he was gay yeah do you know I
mean he's gay he's got to be gay
look look at the outfit you orange Crocs
blue and light blue striped socks
[ __ ] what do you call that plaid
shorts blue a green vest orangish
button-down under it and an orange tie
and orange goatee and an orange long
hair and yeah obviously go up up a bub
bub when you grab girl spots
there's no
in Mario Batali's Italian dude I'm so
sorry for all the sexual harassment and
I know this is inappropriate but I just
want you to know if you are looking for
[ __ ] cinnamon flavored [ __ ] on the
holidays here you go
I'm sorry I am sorry it doesn't mean you
don't want to [ __ ] have a good taste
bud good good taste during the holidays
anyway these are good Cinnabon cinnamon
shits and also turn around
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh buhbuh let me grab
your butt's now it's all good Mario
Batali
I mean plaid shorts with a green vest
that's it that's all I got to say when
they said you really [ __ ] sexually
harassed a bunch of women all you had to
do was say plaid shorts and a green vest
bye and then go wee